[Music]
hey man it's me kevin smith welcome to
masters of the universe
revelation celebration a celebration of
the writers behind
masters of the universe revelation i'm
sitting right next to one of those said
writers
right now ladies and gentlemen tim
sheridan
um brought i i can't
i can't under sell tim
sheridan as a writer um he came into my
life by way of probably teddy right
yeah yeah yeah well i knew rob too uh
yeah i
had met with rob before but yeah teddy
and i've known you forever
like the never mind the writing
that you get out of a tim sheridan like
that's just [ __ ] top-notch because
you've probably seen his work
right now he's got long halloweens out
what was the other dc things you did
uh you know i've done reign of the
superman and superman man of tomorrow
those were movies i've done a lot of tv
shows
for them i got dc comics i'm working on
now at teen titans academy
uh shazam mini series so lots of them
look at the humble bragging
and what about um what about the tv
stuff
then you do uh transformers yeah
transformers were for cybertron also on
netflix
uh did season two and three of that so
long tail
a lot of [ __ ] writing particularly in
the genre
so um i remember teddy was like i got
this guy
tim man i think you should meet with him
he's i think he'd be great in the room
he knows motu as well and so
not only did we get great stuff as
promised said tim just as a writer
but tim in this episode the presentation
of the script even
was so delightful because this is our
scareglow episode
and you know the first time that we get
to actually play with that character
in this iteration of masters of the
universe they probably did in the mike
young production no
no this is his first time on screen
they've never they didn't do them in the
mic
oh my god i'm gonna i'm gonna get i just
assumed they did everything in mike in
the mike young version i am
99 sure that he's never been on screen
so this could be it
this was a character that started as an
action figure
that never made it on to the cartoon
because the cartoon was cancelled
by the time the action figure was in
production or out there in the world so
they stopped making the filmation
cartoon so scare glow never got to be
in the cartoon same with clam champ i
believe
um so uh the idea here was like oh we
get to play with him for the first time
and he is represented as our lord of
hell in our storyline
but what tim did in just writing a
script which i was like i will
take with me for the rest of my life
whenever he wrote scareglow's dialogue
he
upper and lower cased it he just made it
look crazy the mad hatter font
the mad hatter font from from the from
well long
roma i had recently scripted long
halloween
and uh it was just i don't know why it
just there was something about it that
made sense for
it's chaotic and anarchic and so as
you're reading it on the page you're
engaged because you're like
oh this guy's [ __ ] up simply because
he just up and lowered up
you know uppercase lowercase and stuff
but [ __ ] like that
like matters because people read this
[ __ ] and so like right away i was like
that's a way right into an executive's
[ __ ] heart man you communicate
so much about the character not with
just the dialogue but just even in the
presentation the script
that's the first thing i mean people
will kind of discount that you think
you're just writing it for the actors to
do it but no
it's got to go through a bunch of people
who have to read it first and uh
and so you know if you can liven it up
on the page you know make it make it
interesting it kind of gave everybody an
idea of the voice that i had in my head
too
which you ended up you know i mean
finding the voice for it
the voice looking at the font
adds to that because when you're looking
at like oh it's gotta be [ __ ] crazy
it's gotta be out there it's gotta be
deep it's gotta be [ __ ] like scary
then we were like oh my god what about
[ __ ] tony could
anybody else could anybody and by the
way
so happy to do it like really like happy
like not for lack of work dude's always
[ __ ] working but like he was like oh
my god
thank you for letting me do this we're
like are you kidding me thank you for
doing it and then impress
too like like when we did the after show
he was
incredibly like oh my god like everyone
in the world is excited for this
people can't wait to see it he's really
on board he played dark side in my reign
of the song
oh did he yeah yeah he's got a great
voice that's where i met him i was just
like who's tony todd
yeah that's right so you work with them
twice it's dope oh yeah um
let's uh dive in shall we this is uh
episode four
kids um do you remember the name of your
and did i
it's it's well it's called land of the
dead now
originally i think it had a title that
was probably a little too
it was reference or it was too it
actually told you a little too much i
think about where we were going what was
it do you remember yeah
it was called fall of a sparrow that's
right yeah so if you see the episode
which you hopefully you have
you'll understand that maybe that's
tipping a little too much that is that
is actually giving away
yeah i think so it's interesting um all
right so episode four
line up your triple zeros and get ready
to press play press and play right now
um here is the uh logo coming up
netflix original uh series we're
watching an old version so r says anime
series
oh right because originally we began
life as an anime
series that's what they were calling us
and then when we were halfway through
they're like this is just an animated
series
land of the dead you're right is the
episode that we went with uh the episode
title we went with
so much better for because obviously we
take place in land of the day
right here now this is the this is um
just to illustrate um how good of a
writer how great of a writer tim is
go on i didn't really touch
tim's script it was so [ __ ] like
pitch perfect
however however this opening
die the opening poem that uh or
children's nursery rhyme
that uh orco is saying that came in
very late in production as when netflix
saw the episodes and stuff
you get notes back and one of the notes
was like hey it's a little dry in there
can we have
can we set up scareglow and sometimes as
writers you take for granted like
oh it's gonna be wicked with scarecrow
but sometimes there are people gonna be
watching this never even [ __ ] heard
of a scare glow never heard the name
and [ __ ] so he needed that needed some
help you're absolutely right about that
and i think that wasn't even my idea i
think that was teddy going like put
something in there this is definitely
nice to have
those guys teddy and rob as i've said
before like
it was like playing [ __ ] it's like
bowling when they put the the bumpers in
the [ __ ]
in the gutters where it's like you can't
lose because these two dudes are like
wow you could do this or do this instead
yeah this was such a better opening too
for the episode
the the chunk that i had written i think
you ended up moving into the very
end of episode three where they arrive
at the gate
to uh so what did what happened
originally in the end of three so that's
how
how uh three no how
four began was was them arriving at the
gate and then
making the decision to you know go in
and uh but to start it
right here it makes so much more sense i
think when you're watching every episode
back to back
yeah the flow of it and it also gave us
a little real estate in
episode four it gave us some nice real
estate and also it gives you a reason to
watch episode four it's like okay
they're just
they're walking in hell what's gonna
happen next and so you get to tune in
and this is you know this was the dream
of a lifetime getting to
create a scene with a whole episode
between
orko and evelyn and let me tell you
something like
i remember i asked ted in the beginning
when we were working on this i was like
who's your favorite character and he's
like evelyn i was like come on ted
nobody's
favorite character is evil in not even
like the girls and he's like no i've
always i thought that character is very
layered very nuanced he's like i've
always loved her and
by the end of this process she became
everybody's favorite character and has a
lot to do
with this episode up till now we've
definitely had
evil lynn as we've known her previously
in the past maybe a bit more well
written
in 2021 and stuff and definitely
sounding cooler as lena heady
but here is where tim establishes the
[ __ ] meat of what evil in will become
um and and we get to hear some some
humanity
in her as she deals with orco and we
also get to
find out orco backstory as well like
incredibly moving stuff that take those
characters
way down the playing field if that's
some sort of analogy to you
a couple of things about that first of
all i was in the middle of scripting
this episode when i got the call
saying that lena had agreed to play so
you got to write to her voice
i ran back opened up the script and
started rewriting
all of evelynn's dialogue because i knew
what she can do
and she just surpassed all expectations
we were scared when she came into the
room
like not scary because she's so powerful
she's incredibly powerful and she also
also very intimidating she's a very dry
sense of humor and stuff which if you
don't know if she's kidding you're like
i don't think this lady likes me but
when she was coming in we were like do
we ask her to do
cersei because that's what we all wanted
was like just
[ __ ] give us cersei man like it's
cersei's voice as evil lynn
and you know mercifully she
you know has a voice and that's she
sounds like cersei so we didn't have to
ask like lena can you lean into cersei
all we had to do was be like lena you
could chew the scenery and she was
able to because like you're animated
everything gets to be bigger and grander
but she also has real subtlety to her
performance which in animation
like you know you never want you want
larger than life but the boys the
pat and adam are directors are so good
they were able to bring
subtle things that she did with her
voice to life you
you need it you need it to really and in
a show like this you've got to have
those quiet moments and i think that
that really helped in terms of setting
up where we're going with her later on
if you you really get to know evelyn in
a different way i think completely in
this episode
and this guy scareglow you know tony
todd i mean it's just un
unreal and this was now in terms of like
writing handing out the scripts and
whatnot i wrote one d
you got episode two uh because it kicks
off like the andra storyline so we're
like give it to dia
she's the one that gets us to
motherboard and stuff like that
um mark had establishing uh
duncan who duncan is now in our story
and orco
i mean setting up set up orco um and
then so you got to do
the human evil in the human orco yeah
um the heroic orco
which is we'll get to later on but more
importantly
scare glow for the first time ever you
get to handle scare glow how do you
approach the character
yeah well scare glow scare glow was
actually an easier in than i thought
because
it in many ways this episode is
and people may the opinions will vary
yours too
i feel like this episode maybe it's just
the way i came at it is more
like a traditional structured more like
a traditional
old sort of cartoon that i watched when
i was a kid maybe you watched
and even maybe even an old uh motu
episode
in that you know we meet this new
villain who has these new powers
the powers are somehow related to
what our heroes are going through they
have to grow
by dealing with his power set with you
know the fear element and that
so in some ways it was very much kind of
very traditional in that way
it's so wild like to hear you break it
down like that never occurred to me but
you're right it's very like
this could have been an episode of
dungeons and dragons in the 80s yeah i
mean of course i think we really tried
to elevate it a little bit when you pat
people like lena
but in terms of structure though it is
very much like all right here's your bad
guy
now we're going to tell you a story and
we're going to jump out to all these
satellites what's funny is we all looked
at this as kind of a bottle episode for
a while in the room and we were talking
about
a bottle of water so so the bottle
episode is the one that sort of sits
outside the story
that you're telling over the course of
maybe a season um
or a series and it can sort of be you
know it lives in its own bottle right it
can be kind of taken out and you can
still follow the whole story
like he would technically he wouldn't
have needed to read episodes one
two three or five to tell his story so
it but it turned out i think we ended up
it's very much it doesn't cardiac yeah
it's it's very much holding story
together i'm going to praise eric
carrasco for a minute if i can't yes
eric is our writer on episode five uh
who we'll see in the next episode
yeah so we talk about everything we're
doing this stuff and we
he looked at a draft of this and he said
you know i think you
need to make room and it was so tight
like there wasn't really a lot of room
for stuff
there was a real page count issue early
on where it was like
at one point it was like 30 pages tops
and they were like no no no more than
15 pages what what's going on but it all
got worked out but yes
no really wisely i needed the outside
eye to say
before i ever showed it to you to say
you need
to do a little bit more with orco here
we've got to set up more and
remember why we love him and fall back
based on what happens at the end that's
the reason you know and so we'll see
that play out but eric uh
was absolutely right normally you shy
away from writing monologues
an animated show but on this [ __ ]
show
this is like a page-long monologue it's
it's monologues of the universe and
griffin magical heartbreakingly such a
secret weapon now
who came up with oracle orco
well you're looking at the guy well no
listen now there is a motu
great [ __ ] line there is a motu
tradition there is a character called
oracle that we met
certainly on screen in the mike young
show and uh and it is implied that that
is like an ancient
orco perhaps from sort of like the way
it's also implied sometimes that
scare glow might be skeletor we kind of
play with that a little bit we don't
really go there but we sort of
acknowledge the fact you have that mind
where he's just like
she's like skeletor and he's like i
remember the name no
no but uh so we acknowledge it but we
don't really necessarily go there right
same thing with orco and oracle
this line right here this magic line
where
evil in kind of shows her heart wears
her heart on her sleeve and talks about
like it's magic
mark this moment because that line is so
strong it winds up defining the next
five
episodes part six through ten um and the
directors
reference it directly like brought it
back that line will return ladies that's
something that's always fascinated me
the concept of sorcery versus
like where she talks about like you know
she's he's
telling the oracle story and she's oddly
even though she's very dismissive
suddenly like you know i've got stories
of my own and i feel a way about magic
and she's talking to one person think
about it she can never have that
conversation at snake mountain
she can't tell [ __ ] skeletor like i
think it's magic he's like you jerk
you can't tell anyone else so here she's
got this guy and she tells she opens up
her heart
a little bit this has the classic kind
of relationship too of two
characters that would never be teamed up
having to
come together work together and bringing
you know finding out a lot about each
other very enemy mind
very the defiant ones finding out
who they are by working together if i
could have written just an entire
season long just the two of them i would
have done it
i would have read it it would have been
amazing obviously here we you know we
get back to the the meat and the
you know the main story and that's
tila's journey and the structure of this
was really nice because
it does you get to jump away we're over
we're with tila
we're with uh beastman and and andra and
roboto
and then we're also with orco and evelyn
like doing three different
stories before we're gonna bring them
all together and here's the man
the the spectral he-man now this is i
say it's you know we're the story of
this episode the
story is the story it's not really it's
tila and he-man's story yeah
and but we see it through what's
happening with tila right now and
it's it's it's part of the the thing
that we knew we were gonna do that you
knew we were going to do right at the
beginning
which was talking about secrets yes the
whole thing is based on deception
we'll go back to this in a second but
somebody on the internet pointed out
this is the first iteration of he-man
where you see his nipples
on either side of the chest plate and i
know that's a patent adam thing probably
an adam thing i want to know who pointed
that out
that's somebody who's really looking but
i've been looking i didn't
didn't have nuts because then i went and
checked it i was like wow they must have
done maybe not in the
1983 but surely mike young put nipples
and no we're the first ones where
they're like hey man
that's where the nips would be do we
ever get a good close-up of the nip
that we might see some hair maybe or
something i don't think they went that
far i think they're more
they're more joel schumacher clean yeah
but still
it was when i hadn't thought about it
when i saw it online i was like right on
another first for us
can i also say something about tiffany
smith amazing i mean she's so amazing
and
i will just it was like i said there
wasn't a lot of real estate in here
you know to be able to develop a lot of
character you really look for
opportunities
andra i thought well this is a good
chance to let her step up and see her in
a leadership role
and uh i just think tiffany plays the
humor
perfectly but then switches and can play
i'm the boss i'm in charge
so very well originally we had a little
bit of a side
note story with the beastman yes i was
gonna say the only things of tim's that
kind of got trimmed out was
there was this beastman clearly
has a thing for dominant women yeah so
like with evil in being gone he kind of
like he defaults to the strongest female
voice and just like he
he says to her like at one point i smell
a fight in the script it's i smell a
fight
ma'am if we
wound up dropping it just by virtue of
the fact that it just felt like
a bridge too far and you don't you don't
have time for everything that's just
what happens you know you get into it
you realize ooh
this scene plays longer we need more
time here so it doesn't serve the story
to
to have those little decides and some of
those editorial decisions too
come from the directors for example
like as tim was talking about like it
used to be
in the beginning of his episode that
they entered uh
subternia the directors are like this
would be a better ending
for episode three episode one
originally went all the way to
um you know them going to snake mountain
yeah you remember that
wow yeah where she was like majestra
sends them to snake mountain
and then picked up like when the
the flashback to to wolf gate because
that's how we also opened three with a
flashback but
to balance the episode they moved a
chunk of one into two and then some
things left
that was great because we really needed
to live in that
episode one a little bit more right as
much as possible you don't notice it
when you're in the room when you're
talking through the story but then you
see it play out and you're like
we want more of this fight we want more
in uh internos
and you want to see their world before
we open their world yeah and so
like there you're seeing oh this fight
is fantastic they did such a great job
yeah
she gets to employ some shady tactics
and
and also these are the moments that are
the most like anime-ish
like when they get into some of the
battle stuff but um they put
these shots of him and her fighting in
the trailer the story trailer yeah
and the you know nobody [ __ ] fell for
it everyone saw his red eyes and most
people like it's faker but they know
that that's not really them fighting and
stuff but
you know this she is fighting a version
of him which is the version she's got in
her head she's trying to deal with
all this [ __ ] that she carries with him
being gone and having lied to her talk
about smart
streamlining getting to the story and
getting through it originally
in the script the first draft had her
fighting a spectral men at arms yeah
then he-man yeah and then spectral tila
and uh the man-at-arm stuff
that was the directors the directors
were like you don't need it
it really did feel like a repeated beat
when you got to he-man well especially
like they had just spent episode three
kind of
healing mending fences with
with duncan yeah so suddenly the idea of
like i still got [ __ ] with duncan
i guess it was like well let's just me
leave it about her fighting he-man and
then her fighting herself because that's
what
i'm so smart that [ __ ] i remember there
was a moment where i was like do we
really
let him punch her like that and they
were like it's not him it's scare glow
it's scare glow and also you just
i mean i i think you have to for this
piece of the story
you have to feel like she could lose
yeah to her fear
you know here and then just to his
gigantic [ __ ]
strength that's true you know like she's
obviously powerful she's got some arms
and stuff but like
this is the most powerful man in the
universe oh and also scarecrow he's no
slouch
this was uh this is kind of dope man
that's when they bring her in and i love
seeing young version of tila
yeah um just by virtue of the fact that
we spent so much time with
this uh grown-up hard-hearted tila
um and uh i love everything the boys did
but i was
you know the haircut i was always like i
liked her long hair
yeah you know later on the hair will
change but you know conceptually you
know where it was kind of like
it's a nod to um supergirl
when uh when what's her sister sister
cut her hair for that season and stuff
i think it looks cool uh i you know but
i mean i i love classic tila but
conceptually i love the idea i love the
fact that they use the old design and
then
she's fighting the new version because
this whole moment is about you're afraid
of
what you're becoming yes and we're
seeing between the two of them that
sort of you know passage of of time and
and growth and it's threading a needle
early too because this is episode four
and what she's becoming doesn't really
get
hardcore addressed until episode six but
we had to start doing it
now so tim has planted it laying in big
seeds
that have everything to do with like the
next
five episodes and like if you've ever
watched a single television program
you're probably already ahead of us and
know
what that's all about but for those of
you who are still like
i don't know what is happening i'm not
going to spoil it for you
but this is an important episode for
the next half of our show something's
going on particularly right here kids
that uh might have a lot to do with
you know what what happens later
regardless of what the specifics of that
are the concept that
tila is coming into her power yeah you
know as a character
just as someone who may have been
uh you know he-man's friend and uh part
of the team
yes but maybe we never saw her come into
her own power
i think we all thought that was a this
was gonna be a good opportunity because
they all do i mean
they all these characters come into
their power in a
they're they're they all engage with the
power in a different way i think of it
as a lapsed catholic story
because you know she was raised in the
faith
and believed everything they told her
and then one day
somebody was like there is no santa
claus and you know she was like
[ __ ] all you liars this shit's getting
personal right now a little bit man
from the man who made dogma i still got
issues
but uh the question is does she will she
have ever returned to the faith
yeah tim i guess we'll have to find out
stay tuned
um this is uh i remember somebody online
was like there's definitely gonna be a
[ __ ] shot
of tula holding the power sword and i
was like i can confidently tell you
that that's not the case and if anybody
uses that as an example i'd be like
that's not the power sword
that's one half of the power sword you
can't do [ __ ] with that sword
you got to get the other half and then
forge them together then you got to post
poke
stab stab that's about all you get it
it's pokey stick that's all she got
yeah um so look at this like teela's won
her battle against herself
and scareglow all of our heroes have had
their moment where it's just like they
got rid of their vanquished their demons
got rid of the darkness figured things
out worked as friends
nothing could be better than all this
and now that we have the [ __ ] sword
this is going to get us into paternia
right
this this half will help us find the
other half it's you know that's
what evelyn is saying you know give me
the sword because you don't know what
you're f and doing you're like
i can do this and um and so
you're a big rings guy right yeah
because this is i was not a big rings
guy i watched them and i didn't read
those books as a child they were like
[ __ ]
this thick i think it's a dick when i
was a kid either
as an adult i wouldn't i probably
wouldn't even do it i definitely
wouldn't do it now
i've had plenty of time and i'm like
yeah i've seen the movies that's enough
but there were a moment this is a very
much a rings moment
isn't it i think so i mean i think so i
think you know
uh anytime you have like the i mean it's
like the sword this like macguffin this
thing and
i what it needed for me that stuff never
interests me there you go that's very
you know uh what is it um you know the
speaker
right um so so yeah certainly visually
we get that here but i
i felt like yeah it needs to be about
like what does evil in bring to the team
here so we're seeing her she's part of
the team let's let's see what it is
these like mage abilities like you know
she's not just like good at magic like
holy [ __ ]
and open the door to heaven and she used
the last bit that she
she felt she had yeah to do it which you
know orco
enlightens us about right here so if
you're like watching if you've watched
the previous episode you're like all
right they ended by going into
hell in this episode they're gonna end
by going into
heaven you don't see this coming because
she's already [ __ ] defeated scareglow
but then this [ __ ] happens my man comes
back for the battle
and everybody tries to just [ __ ] run
for it they don't want to fight again
and stuff but they get trapped and
this is where you know people win emmys
kids
this is where tim wins his emmys this is
where griffin wins his
emmy they have emmys for cartoons they
better yeah they got annie's right
kitties for everybody um this
uh was a moment as we were in the
writers room and we were like
you know look he's already depowered
he's already kind of sick
what if he got to go out a hero that's
why tim
layers it on so [ __ ] thick you know
in
in the backstory department when he's
talking about like not being good at
anything and when
evil lynn is like that's your parents
talking and [ __ ] like that that sounded
like an incredibly person
i love that i don't know right how would
you know you know
exactly but like here we felt like
what if he's the guy what if he saves
everybody what if it's the little boy
against the [ __ ]
powers of hell it's what i've waited for
my whole life is to see orco come into
his power the way that everybody else
comes into their power in this episode
earn the hero badge that we saw on
episode
so many people are dismissive of orco
and you know we can kind of laugh and
he's a funny character but
and that's what his whole what he's
saying in the beginning you know people
laugh
it's now there's nobody left to laugh so
what do i do now i become the [ __ ]
hero
so awesome when he goes he can't scare
me yeah ugh
um all of this i remember crying when i
read the script and i knew what was
coming
you sent me a little video clip of you
crying after you read so [ __ ] good it
still [ __ ] kills me
and then you throw on the i've watched
it without a bear mccreary scorer for so
long oh i read it without a bear
mccreary score
he [ __ ] gives of orco the heroic
theme if you listen closely
he takes orco's like goofy theme and
turns it into this epic
tragic moment so we felt like look kids
are going to watch this
is primarily we're making this for
grownups but they're going to bring
their kids into it
orco is a child's way into this show and
what better thing to show a kid than
like
you can be a hero too it's not always
just the adults like even the smallest
can make a difference man and this end
yes
you may die but you know that's all part
of it as well
uh yeah i mean it's it was awful it
killed all
remember we were all agonizing over this
and
it was like do we are we really gonna do
this agonizing but also like yeah let's
[ __ ] do it well there was
certainly the bloodlust kicked in but
but when you think about it he's you
know he's an important iconic character
but but
i think what we settled on was the idea
is that
he is so magical as a creature as a
character
and the point here is that the magic is
dying
and there it kind of isn't a place for
him
in this new version of of the universe
oh it's so sad
and so true i showed my kid this moment
the other day
because she was like i like that little
guy i was like orco let me show you his
whole arc and i even showed her this and
she
[ __ ] bawled she was like why
like you sound like the internet that's
what they're gonna say too
i was like just trust your father this
will make sense one day i think this is
another great example of being dialed
back by smarter people because i'm
pretty sure in the script i had his
death be pretty gory yes it was a little
more graphic
it was we actually saw his face too i
think in one version of it like before
he dies
you see his actual face but powerhouse
was just like come on
yeah no they were right they were right
sometimes i like to touch the stove
steal some cookies see what happens i
would have liked to have seen what that
looked like but i'll be honest with you
probably best that that we've never seen
no it's still in his
last moment because that's all anyone
who would ever talk about it's like oh
remember what he looked like
here they talk about him dying a hero
and then oh
here he is which we owe that moment you
know end episode five
which eric wrote uh to the great john
ostrander
i've told this story before uh inasmuch
as
uh a character who's a main character
dies and goes to heaven
and then that person is gonna have to
make a choice to leave
paradise to help their friends john
ostrander did that in grim jack
years ago that storyline i [ __ ] loved
it
so when i wrote green arrow years later
that's what i did and when i pitched
this
i was like what if he
he what if we ostrander this what if he
dies and he's in heaven and they get to
see him in heaven and then the big
choice is like
do i stay or do i go um
set up fantastically by tim as we head
into
episode five let me tell you this stuff
is a team sport and uh you know
with mark and dia and eric and you and
rob
and teddy and and the folks at
powerhouse yeah pat and adam our
director is also
like it is very much a stew
it's like stone soup it's that [ __ ]
story from childhood where it's like
everybody brings something from home and
i've got a magic rock
and the magic rocks post megan soup and
everything that everybody brings
to it and even moments like that like
moments like that line like
that's your parents talking that will
connect with an audience you know you
could say
like i loved writing the faux
shakespearean dialogue and [ __ ] like
that
but when you say something real like
that you got to realize that like
think about it there are going to be
parents and kids watching this episode
together
a moment like that a line like that
could have a healing effect
you could be like you know if you're the
kind of adult that gives a [ __ ] about
your kid enough to like sit down and be
like watch this thing because i used to
like it when i was a kid
and that line hit you in a specific way
you might re-evaluate your relationship
and be like oh [ __ ] like
maybe i want to be more supportive and
stuff like that yes we get to play that
beat again in the second half with with
king randor as well
that's the stuff i love and i feel like
you know when i was
when i was a kid i always reached for
stuff that people told me
was outside of my reach of understanding
as a kid but i always reached for it
and i think it helped me grow i'm
stretching for all that stuff
and uh and and i have a secret right
there people like how do i write like
that
lean your kid into like porn he says
grown-up materials just give him growth
that's
what i'm saying let's give an example
what is like like well for me
it was it was the old classic 86
transformers the movie
which was just way too old for somebody
who's a kid you know
we were familiar with jeff yeah we all
watched the show
and it was no consequences at the end of
the episode
you know lasers miss each other nobody
really gets hurt
and everything's reset and we do the
next episode right and then you go into
the movie
and like the first thing that happens is
the bad guys die or the good guys die
sorry and the bad guys win and then
optimus prime
dies and i'm sitting there i'm like a
kid staring at the screen what did they
do to my childhood
but i was riveted and and
i learned the lesson that nobody else
was going to teach me at that point
that sometimes the good guys lose it's
true
and it's and it doesn't mean that it's
over it makes for a compelling story
it makes you even more interested in the
story yeah it's very easy to get bored
of like you know look if you look at the
old episodes of masters universe
pretty formulaic and he's always going
to win at the end of the day and stuff
so what teddy our boss gave us marching
orders for was like
just make me give me stakes make me
believe that
anything could happen to them that they
could die and you're right now
that you [ __ ] say that like that's
how i should have been out there on the
internet all this time
going like look remember the
transformers movie
compared to the transformers tv show
that's what we're talking about here
it is it's just like we give them stakes
we grow it up a little bit same thing
all the characters you know and love
we're not like
that was all a lie we're like that was
all the truth but this is what happens
when one of them drops dead
but also when we deal in nostalgia which
is what we
i certainly do a lot yeah my stock and
trade as well yeah
but but the idea i think the the way it
always works best is when we
give you the thing the feeling that you
remember
feeling when you first watched the old
show or even more
when you played with the toys yes
because the stakes and the drama were
i don't know about you they were so much
higher in the game exactly these
cats characters died all the time in my
bedroom when i'm playing with the toys
an excellent point
yeah but that's the feeling we try to
evoke and if we do that and that's what
then
the folks who grew up with it connect
with it and the kids who are watching it
get to reach for that the way that i
reached for transformers the movie
we saw that with the teaser people's
reaction to the teaser like peeing like
oh my god it looks like my childhood
come to life
but really if you go back and look at
those episodes you're like come on
your childhood never looked like this
right like this
this animation is incredible like you
know i'm not saying like that had
nothing to do with me that has to do
with powerhouse but like
it is that there's a huge difference
between what you remember about that
show
and that show itself so you know like
for years i've been going this is a
spiritual sequel to the filmation show
spiritual is the big word there not
sequel
spiritual because if we were literally
sequalizing that show
you couldn't it's it's episode we would
just make 10 episodes where they go on
adventures and somebody gives a moral at
the end of it
and you know that's what you can get
from the
he-man and the masters of the universe
show that they're doing the the cg one
the kind of all-family show and stuff
this was meant to be the continuation
of the classic storyline just with
everybody kind of more mature
i don't know about you but i i my
instinct when i hear people say stuff
like that was like you know this looks
just like
i want to fight i want to fight like how
dare you so
look look at how this looks it looks so
much better but the fact is the cat bird
sees though yeah it means that we did
our job
and it's like the illusion is working
because people are like
oh my god it looks exactly like my
childhood and it's like it looks better
but that's okay
boy nobody's as big a fan of us as us i
think we love this show
we've been living with this show for
like two [ __ ] years man that's why
i'm so glad that it's out there in the
world and other people can see it and
we'll see if we were right we'll see
but i don't think we're just butt
sniffing i don't think we're like oh man
[ __ ] our [ __ ] don't stink like
we managed to make a wonderful little
epic
ladies and gentlemen big adventure epic
and and for me
it was like something i don't normally
do tim plays with the big toys
all the time batman transformers stuff
like that picking up somebody else's
toys is a little nerve-wracking but i
honestly feel like
any masters of the universe fan would
feel like my god you guys
treated just like bear bear was like i
watched this show when i was growing up
when i read your scripts he was like i
was blown away at how seriously you were
treating it
when i saw the animatics couldn't
[ __ ] believe and when i saw the final
animation he's like that's why i had to
hire an orchestra
to do my score he's going like you guys
are playing at a high level
like and not that like we're brilliant
he's just going like you're playing it
seriously we're all treating it
incredibly seriously
we felt safe because we had
rob and teddy now they're not infallible
gods among them they pretty much are
when it comes to this [ __ ] to motu
other things in life maybe not but like
those two guys and masters of the
universe like i said they were our
bumpers man
but for us to have that feeling of
safety when we're writing it when we're
just brainstorming coming up with stuff
and collaboration remember like shetty
was there when we did our first writer's
room session we're all sitting on
couches teddy's like kneeling on the
floor on the table
crawling around going like oh you could
do this yes throwing in ideas he was
doing his cringer
yes so it was it's there's a reason we
like it so much
um so much so that here then you're a
guy that does a thing and then you move
on and do another thing you're a
journeyman yeah well i
have been yeah what is like i had such a
good time with this
like it makes me a little nervous about
doing it again because i'm like it'll
never be that wonderful
you know i'm at a point and this is just
you know this happens like probably to
everybody i don't know
you had a different experience sort of
coming into this you kind of like you
followed your dream you did a thing and
it was real big and splashy and you know
you got to kind of do
i came in the back door you got to do
well
so to speak what what am i implying
no uh i'm at a point now where i'm
starting to look at stuff now that
this show is the one of the first times
that i've ever watched the final product
after i
handed off the script and went and felt
good [ __ ] off and did what i want to
do i came back to it and i'm like
oh my god this is everything i dreamed
of anymore yeah
sometimes you watch it and you think i i
wish i had a seat at the table
i wish i could have given a note here
and there on this thing you know
tim not only were like [ __ ] had a
seat at the table and gave notes on his
episodes and stuff
he also like we had they weren't called
for no one wanted them yeah it was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] your notes
um but if we did a watch along we were
watching
the episodes and there was one moment in
episode one
where you were like you know like i feel
like
like to set up the adam king randor
thing that we know that we're doing in
the back half
he's like he really should come at him
harder
or at least be critical because he
wasn't in the original draft he wasn't
really critical adam was like
look at duncan you know he's beaming
with pride and i think the original
line was like um
um that's parental pride adam something
you'll feel one day when you're a father
implying that he's proud of his kid
but tim was like that's the only thing i
bumped into he's gone because
in order to land where we're gonna land
he can't be proud it was also because we
were going into working on the comics
yeah the prequel comics and that was
which tim
wrote the dark horse books yeah but that
was because the
relationship between randor and adam was
a key point in the comics
and i thought ooh in order for this to
sort of marry and make sense
it felt like we were missing an
opportunity there with one line in the
first episode
i thought my mind changes and it changes
everything i said it out loud and i'm
like there is
we watched every episode that day and i
was like there's no way kevin's gonna
remember that line
from episode one that and then like i
don't know a couple weeks later he sent
it to you you said it to me you're like
hey great note thanks
made all the difference because then the
line goes for him being like that's
parental pride
adam something i hope i can feel one day
as your father line completely changes
and you're like what a dick
really swung in the other direction but
buys us where we eventually have to go
it also buys
his big reaction to he-man's death
finding out that he man was adam yeah
so he feels this betrayal and [ __ ] like
that and it's also you could tell
because his whole life he you know kind
of treated adam less than he could have
and stuff
he championed he-man but adam was like
you should be more like he-man and stuff
so yeah this is some beautiful crap man
this is
there's a lot of parental stuff in this
episode i mean they're right
i i don't even think i consciously knew
that there was a lot of parental it is
in retrospect you know we did an issue
with the comics
the third issue is basically the evil in
issue yes
which ties in heavily to evelyn's story
in a big way i mean it should
but it really does and that to me was
the thrill of a lifetime
after having written evil in the show
with lena's voice in mind so now you can
write to that voice
oh baby man evil in card or comic book
spin-off series please that's what
right especially like well i mean i
don't they gotta one day you'll see the
back five but wait till you see where
the character gets to go
um there's some great great stuff which
really sets up a wonderful future as
well
um but man oh man killed it right
took us to hell and [ __ ] killed it
was the absolute right man
for the job for heaven's sakes and
pleasure to read your [ __ ] scripts
tim wrote uh one in the first five and
then two in the back
right yeah yeah yeah and i can't let me
just i can't thank you enough this was a
wonderful experience i didn't know thank
you
you literally like [ __ ] made it
better um
so like ted proof that ted be a sully
like knows what he's doing he was like
there's a guy who'd be perfect and
he was absolutely [ __ ] perfect is
perfect thank you
for making this thing and i've watched
it so many [ __ ] times
and i i cry over and over when he when
he dies
every [ __ ] time so well fine i'm
gonna be a pariah
you know that yeah well they should
blame kevin look he could have stopped
it i'll just say this
if you've ever seen television or movies
before
you know come on come on
do you really think i don't know
well don't tell don't get their hopes up
over you know
something i'm just saying it's a long
life kids
long life not for orco he died no he but
you never know other stuff magic has a
way of
dot-dot-dot uh in any event uh give it
up for the great tim sheridan ladies and
gentlemen
he did you justice and don't forget if
you haven't
go out and get the dark horse tie-in
comics uh it's three issues right four
four and with gorgeous [ __ ] covers
gorgeous artwork
yeah mindy lee's stuff looks incredible
absolutely wonderful so
please if you like revelation that
series is uh written by one of the
revelation writers and and we have a
story about you and robert
yeah so it's like it ties in it ain't in
a junk that's like
oh you know i guess like this is just to
remind us of the characters it
it's i'm not saying without it you won't
understand revelation but
with it oh my god revelation will be
that much richer for you
uh there it is kids for uh masters of
the universe revelation celebration
celebration of the writers of mass of
the universe man
tim sheridan has been our guest hire
this man kids
if you've got any control or grow up to
be this cat take your life lessons
when we didn't ask when did you want to
start writing when did you figure out
you wanted to be a writer oh man
for the longest time i told myself i
could not be a writer
why because i thought oh other people do
it better
and so therefore why would i ever try
which is why i try anything
right it's like a trick that we do with
a mind trick that we use on ourselves
and it was what happened man one day i
woke up and i was like however
there are a lot of hacks who make a
really good living
and i can do at least as good as that
and that's like something a lot of
people like when people used to attack
me on the internet well i hate you and
your [ __ ] your [ __ ] sucks
i'm always like great i apologize yeah
i'd be like tim [ __ ] one day we might
write together
but when they do that i would always be
like look that's
great but if i'm you i'm not wasting my
time telling me how much you don't like
me
i'm using that fire to get where i want
to get to
like tim was like you know i'm not good
enough but then he was like you know
what
i've watched a lot of [ __ ] where people
are bad enough and they got the job so
why not me
man so that ain't him being like i'm
better than these [ __ ] but it's him
going like
if that's allowed then i definitely have
a shot particularly because i know what
i'm doing i think i can give them
compelling [ __ ]
it's like i'm not going to write right
to the lost ark who is going to write
raiders of the lost ark now
you know um but hey i can make a living
i've done more than that you're making
high art my friend [ __ ]
long halloween how surprised were you
you weren't crucified oh my gosh people
the response
really really really which i'm surprised
because that's again that's you're
taking
an iconic thing everybody knows that
book yeah and you know you
it by virtue just by virtue of the fact
that you're translating it
into cinema something that's a monthly
comic book
you know a whole different way of
telling a story slow burn too right
which doesn't really
necessarily work in a movie i thought
the choices we made
were you know going to be really tough
to pass
uh you know muster for the fans but you
know people really dig it with it
they really dug it so it's good he's
he's he's dc in you man
he's making all your favorite dc [ __ ]
come to life over dc
um and here he brought [ __ ] life to
scare glow
in all our characters um if you love
what he did in episode four
kids wait till you see what he does what
did you have seven and nine no seven and
nine
seven and nine yeah like amazing you
heard it here first
episodes yeah that's right nobody yeah
we know i guess we're spoiling them
uh there it is i guess it's information
that there is a seven and nine too
technically they weren't guaranteed that
they'll they'll be they
yes there's a seven and nine tim wrote
them and you'll love them uh there it is
kids for
uh massive universe uh revelation
celebration i'm kevin smith
i'm tim sheridan and uh you
have the power
this is the cat greetings everybody
and welcome to the aka ask if anything
every saga has a 10-year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with jay and sam bob get old i'm
kevin smith